get ready to fill your balls with semen
that is the message of GI Joe
retaliation this movie is a definition
of testosterone fueled cinema it's
seriously like a little boys wet dream
they got buff guys guns gadgets swords
explosions soldiers ninjas everything
except titties now you're probably
thinking this guy loves the movie no
there are things about it that I do love
but then there are things the better
than are quite boring the first act is
great awesome set of characters great
action sequences a real sense of fun but
what are the best things about this
movie is barely in the film is that my
friends is Shannon Tatum him and Dwayne
Johnson have such good chemistry
together and there's a natural charm
that's brought to life with just his
presence however he's barely in it
visitors Dwayne not the rock Johnson
this guy just gets better every movie
he's a new leader the GI Joes and he was
perfectly cast to helm this movie and
take over yet again another franchise if
you ever wonder what a tissy T the
Rockies will they answered in this film
he's black there's some awesome action
sequences in the first half of act 2
especially the mountain fighting ninjas
ain't Snake Eyes played by a ray park
you might know him better as Darth Maul
is a badass I enjoyed watching Storm
Shadow he too is a badass but after the
midpoint of this film it starts to drag
the film has really no characterization
at first it does but then they drop it
the film suddenly loses its sense of fun
the action sequences begin to feel very
repetitive even with a shot of London
being blown the [ __ ] up you're still
just like one of the biggest problems of
this film is to kill off like all the GI
Joes in the beginning of the movie
leaving you with just three remaining
Joe's Dwayne Johnson and two other very
boring people one's a guy named Flint at
first he's cool rebellious does some
cool flips then he suddenly the most
boring dude
this movie then there's a hot [ __ ]
she's hot that's about as far as her
talent goes there's also so many bad
guys then nothing feels personal it's
like which enemy do we really want to
see die and towards the end of this
movie the movie starts to lose sight of
who the lead is the biggest
disappointment was the use of Bruce
Willis's cameo he's not bad in the movie
they just didn't know how to take
advantage of the old guy The Rock says
he's the reason we're called Joe's they
get to bruce willis and here we go game
changer but now they just turn them into
a simple small character and just
because it's bruce willis does not mean
the character is suddenly interesting
but honestly the first half of this film
is so much fun the last half has so much
explosions that you just feel like
[ __ ] people up by the end of this
movie so for all the action and I'd say
the first half let me get straight to
the point here all at all i gotta say GI
Joe retaliation got it right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
video why don't you go ahead and scroll
to the comment box and tell me your
points below if you want to see a more
in-depth review of GI Joe retaliation
check out my show call the reasons to
see that I do with my buddy Jerry where
we give you reasons to see and not to
see GI joe retaliation last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time a new review is out go ahead and
subscribe to my channel